Bruce Arians the coach of the Buccaneers
has been making the rounds and one of
the things that came up yesterday there
were some in the media that got smitten
with this idea that once Tom Brady
agrees to terms with the Buccaneers it's
gonna be like an NBA team where all
these free agents flocked to Tampa to be
with Tom Brady and it really hasn't
happened I mean they're hat like Joe
Haeg who like there haven't been a lot
of free agents who have chosen the
Buccaneers in the past week one of the
things Arian said yesterday we had some
guys call but there's only so much money
that can go around and look that I just
don't know that there's a laundry list
of great great players out there that
can say hey I want to go play with Tom
Brady and I think the key is just
keeping the guys that you like and you
believe in like an endowment kansui and
project forward how he's gonna perform
with Tom Brady there so I don't know how
much of that we're gonna see now look
there's a chance some players will get
cut you know that happens recognizable
names get released all the time and
maybe some of those guys will try to
make a beeline to Tampa Bay but there's
cash issues salary cap issues we have to
remember those as we go forward Chris I
mean look I don't know that it really
matters I don't know how quickly you can
mash together a team of superstars and
have it work anyway I kind of like the
Buccaneers
having the continuity having the guys
they know having the guys they like and
plugging in a guy that they think is
gonna elevate the players that they're
already comfortable with yeah I think
they got to recognize that you're right
I mean first off the team has talent you
know like we saw last year they could
have been a pain in the butt if Jameis
Winston you know didn't have a few games
where you know he cost them wins and and
he was a big reason of why they lost but
yeah I do I think you know Tom Brady's
kind of the finishing touch you know you
know the he's the he's the icing on the
on the top of the cake here as far as
kind of just bringing everything
together for kind of a young immature
team that doesn't know how to win and
hey the head coach can only lead so much
you need guys like this but yeah Mike I
don't expect like big-time superstars I
don't think Jadeveon Clowney is gonna
call down to Tampa and be like hey I'll
play for five million dollars less just
to play with Tom Brady know he might
want to play with Tom Brady but he's not
crazy and he's not going to do
so yeah there is only so much money to
go around to me the signings you might
see as we get a little later in free
agency is some veterans who might be in
that you know I can't like aka like a
Ben Watson who I know retired but that
type of guy in theory where I'm just
saying it's the end of his career all
right and he's got offers her a few
teams and he might take a few hundred
thousand dollars less or a million
dollars less to say you know what I want
to enjoy my last year or two of my
career I'm gonna go to Tampa Bay and
take a shot with Tom Brady and see how
it works out to me those are the type of
guys I could see kind of signing on here
later on in free agency and there's been
some fascination about Rob Gronkowski
possibly coming out of retirement to
join Tom Brady they have OJ Howard and
Cameron Breit they don't really need
drunk and he still continues to be the
property contractually of the New
England Patriots he's on their reserve
retired list they'd have to let him go
before he could go to Tampa Bay and who
knows maybe the Buccaneers would have to
give something up to get Gronk if it
even comes to that but there hasn't been
any serious talk along those lines
another thing that Bruce Arians said
yesterday Chris that caught my attention
he said that the perception that Tom
Brady can't throw the deep ball is just
wrong who has the perception that Tom
Brady can't throw the deep ball well
yeah I you know I understand what he's
saying a little bit you know I was a big
proponent like three four or five years
ago of man Tom Brady's one of the worst
deep ball throwers in football you know
that's you know what they did that year
that was the year they drafted Jimmy
Garoppolo in the second round you know
because they thought oh New England
thought man maybe it's coming to the end
for Tom Brady they didn't draft Jimmy
Garoppolo because they were like let's
let him sit on the bench for the next
six years and we'll trade them somewhere
no they were worried about Brady's play
so they drafted Jimmy Garoppolo because
they were worried and Brady when I was
working there was one of the worst deep
ball throwers in football and it was
something that was constantly being
worked on from an accuracy standpoint or
an arm strength standpoint know from an
his arm strength know exactly right is
his arm strength is top-notch it's
underrated as far as where Tom Brady's
arm strength is but you know he became
such a machine he's so accurate
such a good decision maker I think he
just was a little bit trying to force
the issue of the intermediate down the
middle de Gronkowski Edelman over the
middle Wes Welker and there was just
opportunities on the outside to throw
the ball down the field which New
England was trying to kind of break him
out of that shell out of that mold to go
hey forced the ball down the field we
can't always get Welker and Edelman over
the middle of the field he's gotten
better in the last two years he's been
much better and I do think with a guy
like Mike Evans you know we're talking
about Tom Brady he's a precision passer
in a lot of ways too we just want to
just throw deep balls up all the time
but now when you have a guy like Mike
Evans this is where I go back and I go
whoa well we met see Brady of like 2007
with Randy Moss Evans is a huge guy huge
catch radius can jump hike and 50/50
balls that takes pressure off Brady too
from having to throw pinpoint accurate
deep balls he can just throw it up and
go hey six five freak of nature
respectfully freak of nature Tim Evans
go up beast that guy catch the ball and
I think with that and seeing his size
and physicality and then a Bruce Arians
in his ear all the time like yeah boy
Tommy keep throwing it deep and yeah
that's great and I think those things
will encourage Brady to even get better
at throwing the deep ball because of
what's around him well I don't know what
Tim Evans can do but I know Mike Evans
can go grab the ball sorry my
psychologist Mike just so you know it's
Tim Evans catch the deep ball as well
and and I think you've touched on
something here that we need to flush out
a little bit more this is about Tom
Brady not having the weapons in the past
that he can trust that have the catch
radius if you've got a guy where you
have to thread the needle 50 yards down
the field you're just not going to throw
the ball and this isn't quite and you
talk about the politics of
quarterbacking where you don't want your
stat sheet to look ugly because you have
a bunch of interceptions on balls where
you throw a deep and your receiver can't
go catch it and the other guy does it's
about the trust level that needs to have
in his receiver you hear about all the
time he needs right have that degree
where he trusts them to make the catch
and if they don't have the downfield
skills he's not gonna trust them he's
not going to throw it I don't think it's
an issue of him not
being able to it's an issue of him not
having the weapons he feels good about
to do it and he will in Tampa he will in
Tampa there's no doubt but Mike I agree
with you I think there is a lot of that
there's no doubt about it you know
throwing a deep ball to a receiver
there's two things that you need there
in the trust tree all right one yeah you
want the guy to catch the ball to you
got to trust the guy that if you do
throw the ball poorly he'll do a good
job to break it up and not let it become
an interception and that is part of
being in the trust tree with a great
quarterback to that hey I'll give you a
chance I'm 5050 balls but either you
catch it or nobody catches it and if
that doesn't happen then you know don't
expect me to keep throwing your balls
deep down the field yeah it can't be
5050 you catch it or he catches it's got
to be 50/50 you catch it or no one
catches it exactly chance will be 10
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports